- Depuis 5 h à matin,
je reçois des téléphones!
(rire)
- La famille de la petite
Madison avait de quoi célébrer
ce vendredi matin.
La fillette qui souffre
d'amyotrophie spinale de type 1
pourra finalement recevoir
le médicament Zolgensma.
ALEXANDRA PEDNEAULT-TREMBLAY,
mère de Madison
- C'est comme si on se
réveillerait d'un cauchemar.
T'sais quand tu te réveilles
d'un vilain cauchemar, puis
le soulagement que t'as que
"ah, ce n'était qu'un rêve!".
Bien on dirait qu'on est
comme... c'est sûr qu'on est
encore un peu dans la maladie,
mais ça nous aide un petit peu
à... ça nous aide énormément!
- Québec a annoncé que cette
thérapie génique, la première
pour traiter cette maladie,
sera ajoutée à la liste
de médicaments fournis
en établissement de santé.
Grâce à une négociation entre
la compagnie pharmaceutique et
les provinces, le gouvernement
du Québec a pu obtenir un prix
acceptable pour le Zolgensma,
qui coûte 2,8 millions $.
Au total, 10 petits Québécois
pourront en bénéficier.
CHRISTIAN DUBÉ, ministre de la
Santé et des Services sociaux
- Je vous le dis, moi j'avais
des frissons cette semaine quand
on a réussi à passer l'entente
avec Novartis. Je pense pas
qu'il y a personne qui va
questionner les coûts
qu'on met là-dedans."
CLIP ANDRÉE LAFOREST, ministre
resp. Saguenay-Lac-Saint-Jean
- Parce que je me disais que le
mois de novembre, pour moi,
c'était comme ma date limite
pour Madison et là on est en
octobre; le 20 octobre
le médicament sera disponible.
- Plus le Zolgensma est
administré tôt, plus il est
efficace. On maximisera donc
les chances de survie de Madison
puisqu'elle le recevra avant
l'âge de six mois.
La maladie sera toujours
présente, mais sa qualité de vie
sera grandement améliorée.
- C'est sûr que tu sais, on va
miser vraiment plus sur les
gains que sur les pertes parce
que t'sais, les pertes vont être
moindres. Ça va vraiment
freiner la maladie.
- Le gouvernement du Québec
espère pouvoir dépister
la maladie dès la naissance
pour prévenir ce genre
de scénario.
- On va essayer même de
continuer la recherche au niveau
du dépistage au niveau natal.
Quand un enfant naît, est-ce
qu'on pourrait tout de suite
vérifier par un test, et tous
les tests qu'on fait quand les
enfants naissent, si l'enfant
est atteint de l'amyotrophie
spinale.
- À partir de maintenant,
la famille de Madison pourra
profiter des bons moments
à venir.
- Là on va pouvoir plus
se concentrer sur elle
effectivement. Au travers toutes
ces collectes de fonds-là,
des fois, on essayait...
on était plus fatigués. A partir
de maintenant, on va pouvoir
plus se concentrer sur elle puis
ses réussites puis ses progrès.
- Pour ce qui est des quelque
650 000 $ qui avaient été
ramassés par la famille,
ils seront remboursés aux
personnes qui souhaitent
récupérer leur argent.
Quant au montant restant,
il sera remis à une fondation.
Philippe L'Heureux,
Radio-Canada, S